[Music]
it's looking pretty grim out there
there's been 66 journalists killed
across the world in 2020 according to
the international federation of
journalists
and there was a record number of
journalists imprisoned across the world
as well in 2020 according to the
committee to protect journalists but
those figures don't even take into
account the deteriorating press
situation that's happened this year in
2021
with a number of countries like belarus
myanmar and ethiopia
falling into civil strife or having
authorities harass
intimidate expel or jail journalists
and below those gruesome headlines
there's also been a number of
less visible hurdles to journalists
trying to do their work
in some cases authorities have
weaponized the visa process
using it to harass journalists or
monitor their work as they try and go
about reporting
it's complicated some do and some don't
some investors point out that a free
media is absolutely
crucial to the healthy functioning of
normal financial markets
but other people point out that there's
no direct
consistent correlation between
oppressing or suppressing media
and having certain investor outcomes
some people point out that you can
invest in a country like china
which has little to no press freedom and
still make money
while other people point out that you
can actually increase or
sustain the positive narrative of an
investment story by suppressing bad
information
but others point out that these
destinations would just inevitably be
better places to invest and better
places for businesses
if you had a freer independent media
a lot of investors say that having a
free independent media
you know along with investigative
journalists and other independent
researchers
is just is just a healthy part of a
functioning economy
a lot of people say that you're less
likely to have fraud corruption
money laundering all these sorts of
things if independent journalists are
able to dig up
and expose a lot of that information
here in hong kong we're in a situation
where we're both a global financial
center
but china is increasing its grip on the
city with a national security law that
has led to a lot of worries and open
questions about whether press freedoms
here are being
eroded yamaha
the last few weeks we've seen
authorities use a national security law
to shutter a newspaper
and effectively block assets and bank
accounts
that eventually forced a media company
out of business
and that's raised a lot of questions
about about what sort of city hong kong
is going to be in the future
you